I told you, in the
last video, that
epoxides are very reactive.
That this little triangle right
here, this equilateral
triangle, is highly strained,
highly unstable.
So it makes it want to do
something, get out of this
configuration.
What I want to do,
in this video, is
to show you a reaction.
What we have, right here, and we
saw this in the last video.
I've drawn a couple
of more hydrogens.
And I've actually drawn a
little bit of the three
dimensional nature of the
bonds right here.
Because it'll matter.
This is cyclo-.
And remember, you can just
pretend like this triangle
here, if it was replaced with
a double bond, this would be
cyclohexene.
But because, instead of a double
bond right here, we
have these bonds to
this oxygen, this
is cyclohexene oxide.
Let's think about what would
happen if we had some
cyclohexene oxide mixed
in with water.
And we have some type of maybe
acid catalyst in there.
So it will allow some
extra hydrogen
protons to float around.
So we have water.
But since we actually put some
acid catalyst there-- and it
could really be any acid
catalyst, anything that would
increase the hydrogen proton
concentration-- we're more
likely to have some hydronium
ions floating around.
And we know what hydronium
ions look like.
They look like water with an
extra proton, with an extra
hydrogen on them.
So hydronium ions
look like this.
This is water.
Let me do it in a different
color since I already used the
blue for the cyclohexene
oxide.
So this is water right here.
What happens to get hydronium
is the oxygen in the water
takes a proton from someplace
else, from some acid, the acid
catalyst, in this case.
It would essentially give
an electron to it.
If this electron gets given to
some hydrogen proton, the
ending result will
look like this.
You have a bond formed with
another hydrogen.
And now, you have a
positive charge.
You have a positive charge on
the oxygen because it gave
away an electron.
This is hydronium.
We've seen it many times.
And this is what results if
you put an acid in water.
It will increase the hydronium
concentration.
You'll see more and
more of this.
So what's likely to happen if we
have cyclohexene oxide with
water as a solvent, but we also
have a good amount of
hydronium floating around?
The more acid we put in, the
more hydronium we'll have.
Well, a possible reaction is,
well let's see, this oxygen is
just as likely, or it may want
to get a hydrogen proton just
as much as a hydronium.
So if they bump into each other
in the exact right way,
this oxygen, right here, could
give an electron to that
hydrogen right there.
And then the original, this
orange hydronium, or this
orange oxygen right here, can
take its electron back.
If that happens, what
do we end up with?
Well, let's see.
So if that happened, now we
have-- Let me draw this
original molecule.
It will no longer be cyclohexene
oxide exactly.
Because it just got
a hydrogen proton.
It's an intermediary now.
Let me try my best to
draw it though.
All right.
We have that.
Then, we have the oxygen popping
out of the page.
It had these two extra electron
pairs, but now it
gave one of its electrons
to this proton.
So now, it gave one of its
electrons to this hydrogen
right here.
I call it a proton, because a
hydrogen without an electron
is just a proton.
It doesn't have another neutron
inside of the nucleus.
So you have the hydrogen
over there.
Now, since this oxygen gave away
an electron, it now has a
positive charge.
Let me draw these two purple
hydrogens that
are behind the page.
So that's one hydrogen there.
One hydrogen there.
Obviously, there's other
hydrogens on these carbons.
But if I drew it, it
would take a while.
It would make a whole
diagram messy.
But it's always assumed
that a neutral carbon
will have four bonds.
And of course, this thing right
here is now just water.
This thing took its
electron back.
I'll draw it here.
This thing took its
electron back.
And now, it's water.
It could be this one.
But there's obviously tons
of water around.
So I could even draw other
water molecules.
It doesn't have to
just be that one.
Now, what is a likely
to happen?
And this is the fun part
of this reaction.
Because it's actually something
we've seen before.
It's a reaction that we've seen
many, many times already.
But it's just not obvious when
you see it in this form.
When you look at this molecule,
right here, what's
going on here?
Well, I already told you that
I have this highly, highly
strained bond here.
It's like this equilateral
triangle.
The bond angles are closer
than they want to be.
The electrons want to get
away from each other.
If you try to do this with a
chemistry model, it would
actually strain the plastic or
the wood of the chemistry
model to actually make it.
On top of that, this oxygen with
this extra hydrogen now,
it is actually a good
leaving group.
And so now, it's probably
triggering some things in your
brain about the type of reaction
that might occur.
And think about this
carbon right here.
Think about this carbon.
Actually, these two carbons
are the same.
So I'll just pick on this one,
the bottom one, for fun.
Think about this carbon
right here.
It is bonded.
It's a secondary carbon.
So it would not be super great
for an Sn2 reaction.
But you can have an Sn2 reaction
with a secondary
carbon, especially when the
leaving group wants to leave
bad enough.
So if one of these water
molecules, it didn't have to
be this first one right here,
if it just bumps into this
carbon in the exact way, it
can actually act as a
nucleophile.
Water isn't, traditionally,
a very strong nucleophile.
But it can be a nucleophile,
especially if the leaving
group is ready to leave
and this is a
really strained bond.
So what you could imagine
is that this
water gives an electron.
It loves this carbon nucleus
right there.
It gives it to that carbon.
And since that carbon is getting
an electron from this
water over here, then it can
release an electron back to
this oxygen, making
it neutral.
So it can release this back
to this oxygen right here.
What will we end up with then?
Now, something interesting
has just happened.
And this is typical of
all Sn2 reactions.
Remember, it's Sn2.
We're substituting with
a nucleophile.
Water is a weak nucleophile.
But, in this case, it'll stick
better than this thing that's
all strained.
And we call it 2, Sn2, because
both of the reactants are
involved in the rate
determining step.
This is the rate determining
step right here.
So what do we end up with?
Let me just draw the hexane
ring, just like that.
Now, all of a sudden, this
oxygen up here, what
will it look like?
Well, this bond gets broken.
It takes back an electron.
So you only have this bond to
the oxygen, this top bond to
the oxygen.
That's the oxygen right there.
It took this electron back.
So now, it has this electron
and the electron that was
bonded to the carbon.
So it has a pair of electrons.
And then, it's bonded to that
hydrogen that it took from the
hydronium in the first step.
And then it's bonded to this
hydrogen over there.
So it really is just an OH group
now, bonded right that.
It's popping out of the page.
You still have this hydrogen
that's going behind the page.
But since we had a Sn2 reaction,
you can imagine this
came from the back.
And this let go from
the front.
So what will now happen is, this
hydrogen that was kind of
behind the page, now
will pop forward.
Because this guy went from even
behind that hydrogen.
So this hydrogen, over here,
will now pop forward.
So this hydrogen, now,
has popped forward.
I'll circle it just so you see
it's the same hydrogen.
But it has popped forward,
since this guy, this
nucleophile attack, happened
from the back.
And now, he is attached.
He has attached down here.
This water has attached.
Well, it's not water anymore.
So you had the oxygen.
Two hydrogens.
And then it had two pairs.
But now, one of the pair
turns into a bond.
Because it gives this
electron there.
So these two guys are bonded.
This electron is given
to the carbon.
And the bond is behind
the page now.
Just like that.
And then the final step is--
now, since this guy gave an
electron, he has a positive
charge here.
Just to make it nice and clean,
you can imagine another
water molecule comes and takes
one of those hydrogens away
from this guy.
All these hydrogens are just
getting passed around between
these water molecules.
So you can imagine this
water molecule
could take that hydrogen.
This oxygen takes the
electron back, and
then becomes neutral.
And then our final product--
we are now done--
will look like this.
So we had cyclohexene oxide, a
reactive epoxide, in water
with some acid around.
So it kind of catalyzed the
leaving group and all that.
We just saw that in this.
But what does the resulting
molecule look like?
So popping out of the page
up here, we have an OH.
That's this right here.
I'm just simplifying
a little bit.
Going behind the page, we have
a hydrogen right over there.
And then, popping out of the
page we have a hydrogen.
So popping out of
the page, right
here, we have a hydrogen.
And then, behind the page,
we have another OH group.
So we've made a diol.
And, in particular, if we wanted
to name this thing
right here, we have our
cyclohexane ring.
That's our main ring.
We have cyclohexane.
And then, we have OH
groups on the-- We
can just start numbering.
We want to start numbering
where the groups are.
So we call this the 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6 carbon.
We have OH groups at the
1 and the 2 carbons.
So we have two of them.
So it's a diol.
So we call this, 1 comma
2-diol, because
we have two OH groups.
Diol.
The -ol is for alcohol when
you have these OH groups.
We have two of them.
And they are on opposite
sides.
This alcohol, or this OH, is
popping out of the page.
This OH is behind the page.
So if we really wanted to be
specific about even the
stereochemistry here, we
would call this trans.
They're on opposite sides.
One is in front.
One is behind.
So this is trans.
This is
trans-cyclohexane-1,2-diol.
So, hopefully, you
enjoyed that.
What the fun thing about this
is, one, to see that epoxides
are reactive.
You just even see
a new reaction.
But the really fun thing to
see is that these Sn2
reactions keep popping up.
In fact, the ones we learned,
Sn2, Sn1, E1, E2, these just
keep, over and over, popping
up in chemistry in places
that, maybe it wasn't obvious
at the first glance.
But then, when you actually
think about it, it's actually
perfect for that type
of reaction.